Okay, I got a pre-dubo scan in January. So we were talking about this pre-dubo scan.
You know, I haven't talked. I got my data a couple years ago and I was happy with the
results of my pre-dubo scan. So I didn't really talk it up that much until somebody else brought
it up in January. So and this person is sharing their experience, which they don't think is
a very good experience. Though the description range about if you'd stronger better than MRIs,
I recently was talking with someone who had one this month and thought her technician said,
it is the same MRI image as the Minneapolis clinic apology. Well, I would question that I don't
think it's the same image as that. Another piece to know is that they are information mighty.
You know, all the detailed questions about ethnic origin and grandparents of details that they
ask on the history. One of the slides just was to sign off on, let's give them permission to use
the information info as they please. And I think that might be just because they're still trying to
gather research on their equipment. Most importantly, my scan did not indicate any lumps in my left armpit,
which are very prominent. So when I asked to question for clarification, they said, is it because
they are lib bill, rather than tumors that didn't show up. This is the person asked this question.
Very good question. They did not respond except to say my report was updated. When I went in to look,
they had added a sentence in the report with no accompanying picture or circle say that I have
bulky asymmetric coalescent left axillary. They had not, but the most likely metastatic in
etiology. So when I called them out on adding it without a picture or answering my question,
they ignored me. Not a professional trust for the action on several levels. Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, it's a radiologist doing that in their human and they make mistakes. Plus, you know, I can't say,
you know, that this is just 100 times better. I just don't know. It's just, that's the way it's,
that's the way it is basically marketed. It's marketed as if the next x-ray and MRI and CT scan and
a PET scan got together had a baby. They're putting up more and more clinics having these, you know,
time will tell. So it's unfortunate that this, that you did not get, you know, the data that you
wanted and don't. And I feel bad about that, but you just, you just got to try it. It's like any test,
I said, these are 100 times. You don't just look at one test. You got to look at multiple tests and
compare data.